this video is sponsored by star trek
fleet command have you ever wanted to go
where no man has gone before you know
into space well now you can and you can
just use your phone to get there
technology star trek fleet command is a
100 free to play open world strategy mmo
available on ios and android basically
whatever you're playing and as you could
imagine because i'm talking about the
game it has a little something for
everybody for lore bugs like me it has a
gripping campaign featuring well-known
characters that you can unlock in the
game as officers and different choice
driven narrative arcs that update each
month with new content and for people
who like to play with their friends a
lot you can enjoy forming alliances so
you can dominate the universe together
or of course play as a freelancer in the
neutral zone
specialize your entire fleet with
research trees send officers out on
resource missions and build your own
perfected space ship all to make sure
you earn friendly renowned with other
factions like the klingons but survive
those who will attack you on sight and
right now they're doing a limited time
giveaway in honor of star trek
discovery's michael burnham so if you
were to reach level 5 today you get
origins burnham as an officer in game
and if you reach level 10 by february
10th which is forever away you'll be
able to tear up officer origins burnham
to rank 2. so what are you waiting for
commander click that link in the
description below to meet me in the
stars today and now on to the video
hey everyone bandit here and it's time i
finally worked up the gusto to be able
to cover not just undertale or deltarune
but the biggest and most mysterious toby
fox character of them all so mysterious
in fact that we don't even know for sure
what he looks like i am of course
referring to the one and several
shattered pieces of wd gaster but i
figured for a character this meta that
has potential tie-ins to literally every
other aspect of either game i would in
contrast start small with a relatively
lower impact theory that builds off of
what most people already assume about
gaster while still remaining interesting
very very interesting i will still go
over who and what wd gaster is briefly
in this video though in order to ensure
everyone is on the same page for better
understanding if you'd like a more
in-depth look at gaster though allow me
to recommend some amazing videos on the
web that were uploaded recently like
this one from misty sparkles or the
gaster egg series from two left thumbs
i'll link to those both in the
description below anyway very quickly
gaster is or rather was a scientist from
the world of undertale as far as we can
tell of course he wasn't just any
scientist either he was the royal
scientist who worked for the monster
king asgore with his entire works
purpose being to harness the power of
determination which is a
feeling or substance apparently that
comes from humans which monsters cannot
normally contain within their own bodies
this is proven to us visually when
undyne literally melts away in front of
our eyes after being determined enough
to refuse to die temporarily in the
genocide route something that only a
human can do and survive apparently
anyway gaster's experimentation if
successful would presumably have enabled
monsters to do that thing that humans
can do where they can just refuse to die
and live on however gaster fell into one
of his creations which shattered his
physical body across time and space
prompting asgore to hire gaster's
replacement alphys in her predecessor's
absence to continue the research and now
gaster is this supernatural element in
the delta tale universe that like i said
earlier has possible ties to everything
and this is by design of toby fox not
even fannin again many of you will
already know this but for those who
don't know we for a fact know that
gaster has reappeared in deltarune or in
the circumstance of delterin but i'll
get to that later we don't have any
visual connections or reappearances of
the presumed undertale gaster sprites in
deltarune but we do have plenty of
textual and auditory evidence to point
to his reappearance for instance
gaster's glitchy muse underscore smile
sound that plays in undertale when
reading the missing lab entry 17 which
is a whole other mystery that i won't go
into in this video also plays whenever
you try to call home from within the
dark world in deltarune the sound is
further described by in-game text as
garbage noise and therefore has a proven
connection to spamton who was on the
phone with someone whose voice sounded
like quote garbage noise the sound is
also played in the light world area
surrounding the mysterious red door
south of the town when you speed it up
that is when you talk to the cat
salesman named seam in castletown and
yes i did that on purpose not only does
his appearance kind of look familiar a
bit but he also says the very very
interesting line darker yet darker which
is exactly what gaster says in
undertale's hidden lab entry 17. but
anyway in a nutshell this is what we
know is canon proven factual information
about wd gaster and i'm pointing this
out because everything else is pretty
much a theory stuff that hasn't been
proven yet so let's get into it first
lots of fans already assumed that
deltarune in and of itself is this next
experiment that gaster was referring to
in entry 17 and for good reason dark yet
darker darkness growing shadows cutting
deeper also known as darkness growing
photon readings negative also also known
as darkness growing yeah it doesn't take
much faith to make the connection
between this and the growing dark worlds
of deltarune which emit darkness out of
them also also also known as darkness
growing especially given the other
evidence we already talked about the
most interesting takeaway from gaster's
words is that this whole dark world
thing is an experiment one of gaster's
experiments that he must have put into
action before his whole time-shattering
debacle took place but one question that
might be raised in light of this
revelation is what specifically is the
experiment is it the entirety of
deltarune as we know it or is it perhaps
just the dark worlds that spawn within
the world of deltarune i would say kind
of both but especially the latter for a
couple of reasons one and this may be
minor to some but as a former indie dev
myself this is very important to me the
menu ui in the light world of deltarune
is exactly the same as it was in
undertale this is important because it
is specifically not the same when you
enter the dark world the menu becomes
much more classical rpg like if you will
from a game design perspective this is
like 1 000 deliberate why go through the
trouble of designing two separate menu
systems unless you were trying to make a
statement about something in this case
clearly that statement is about the
difference between the light world and
the dark world the light world is
supposed to look and feel familiar even
though it may appear different does that
you can always come home music track
sound familiar well it's supposed to it
is literally the same tune as the home
music from undertale just plus the added
deltarune theme after the his theme
portion in a game which largely features
completely new environments and new
music this is also a very telling piece
of evidence to me this clearly means
that there is a difference between the
familiar light world and the newly
spawning dark world one that ties in to
gaster i personally believe that the
light world is the same world that
undertale takes place in and let me be
specific i'm not commenting in this
video whether i believe deltarune is the
same or different universe as undertale
if you would like my complete collected
thoughts on that check out my genocide
timeline theory that i will link to
below what i'm saying here is that
deltarune's dark world as we know it is
probably the experiment that gaster
spoke of but only the dark world not the
light world outside of it as far as how
gaster is able to open the dark worlds
i'm not completely sure but caster is a
character that is so meta that he
literally has spoken to us through
twitter before like real life twitter so
there are many many ways that could
serve as explanations here so once again
fill in the blank now the final question
is what is the purpose of gaster's dark
experiment why is gaster's experiment
remember what gaster's entire purpose
was as a royal scientist before his
shattering he tried to harness
determination he tried to form it into a
substance from the human souls that
asgore claimed and bend it to his will
only things went wrong we know this not
only because of his own self-destruction
but also because of his successor
alphys's failed determination
experiments that resulted in the
creation of the amalgamates which were
all dead monsters that alphys failed in
trying to bring back to life with
determination i mean she was successful
but they became even more monstrous than
before you get what i'm saying wouldn't
it then make sense that gaster's next
experiment would also tie into his prior
experiments with determination which was
the entire purpose of the core lab now
we could say that gaster is therefore
experimenting with the only known human
soul in the deltarune universe presently
chris's soul by opening the dark worlds
and having chris enter them in yada yada
but i think it goes deeper than that
remember that gaster is super meta
breaks the fourth wall talks to us on
twitter think about that gaster talked
on twitter to us to you to me humans in
real life when you boot up the game and
start from chapter 1 gaster speaks to
you says we're connected and remember
what the first name for deltarune's game
icon was survey underscore program i
still have it on my desktop a survey one
could say is a type of experiment one
that tests results wouldn't you say and
the only person taking that survey is
you the human he even said it outright
in his tweets on halloween of 2018. he
said quote to be here finally on the
verge of connection is quite exciting
now show yourself deltarune after
teasing his next project the previous
day and then we downloaded the survey
program and the first thing he said to
us was are you there are we connected
excellent this implies that the soul
that you see materialize in front of you
and throughout deltarune is in fact your
soul not the soul of chris not the soul
of frisk not the soul of chara i prefer
to say chara not kara because kara
sounds dumb and your determination is
what's being put to the test or survey
researched and then experimented on
again in a new follow-up chapter that's
how it works in chapter one gaster was
testing how we the wielders of
determination respond to a lack of
choice which chapter 1 was notoriously
void of in chapter 2 gaster gave us a
familiar genocide-like choice again
called snow grave within his
experimental dark world and as many fans
point out it's not chris that tells noel
to perform the deadly snow grave spell
which we can tell because noel is
talking to you not chris but on the
other hand how would you the player even
know what snow grave is unless gaster
revealed that choice to you he did so in
order to determine how many of us would
choose to kill given the opportunity or
something else that he wants to figure
out the point is gaster has seemingly
discovered a way to connect us to the
world of delta tale his world and
subject us and our determination to his
newest experiment within his experiment
on real life human souls perhaps his
shattering across time and space was
actually deliberate on his part so that
he could leave his own world and connect
to us in hours perhaps this is all
according to gaster's plan his own
determination to harness the power of
humans and it all takes place in his
dark yet darker experiment deltarune now
this theory isn't going into any of the
nitty-gritty gaster details like what
he's doing behind that mysterious tree
or what his purpose was with confronting
jevel or spamton and turning them nutty
although an explanation could definitely
fit within the parameters of this theory
i mean if he is the creator of the dark
worlds and therefore the characters
within the dark worlds perhaps he was
corrupting them to determine how
determined we the humans are in
confronting secret bosses but there's
literally no way to determine for sure
at this present time hey here's a
drinking game idea take a shot every
time i say determine in this video
anyway this is all of course just my
theory what do you guys think though is
gaster experimenting on us the real life
humans with real life determination or
am i way off and gaster hasn't quite
broken through that much of the fourth
wall yet let me know in the comments
below also thank you so much for
watching please leave a like below on
this video if you enjoyed it to help get
it spread around on youtube and
subscribe to stick around for more very
very interesting videos about your
favorite video games a huge thanks of
course to my bandit crew who help every
day to make these videos possible
especially in the holidays if you're
interested in helping the channel remain
alive please consider checking out that
join button below or the patreon link in
the description that's all i've got for
this one so as always i hope you have a
wonderful rest of your day this is
massington abandoned determined to see
you next time and signing out
[Music]
you